do you think adults convicted of
sexually assaulting children should go
to prison Rishi sunak doesn't
or at least that's what labor is saying
[Music]
they've done a series of ads taking aim
at the Prime Minister and not everyone
in the party thinks they've hit the
right note
[Music]
so-called attack ads are nothing new in
politics but this one has caused a storm
on Twitter and a rift between some in
labor
so does negative political campaigning
work and what are the risks
I'm Leah belletto and this is the Sky
News Daily
now don't worry if you didn't spend your
Easter weekend scrolling through Twitter
and you haven't seen these ads yet
because political correspondent Liz
Bates did so Liz can you explain exactly
what these ads look like
yes so first of all I think it's good if
you didn't spend your Easter glued to
Twitter as some journalists did so I
will describe Those ads it's a series of
ads uh that are personal attacks I think
it's fair to say I'm really soon AG they
were released on social media the way
what they look like and they all follow
the same format is there's a picture of
Rishi sunak looking very Smiley and
Prime ministerial I'll read out the one
for you that's been most controversial
so it says do you think adults convicted
of sexually assaulting children should
go to prison Rishi sunak doesn't that's
next to a picture of his face and then
if you carry on reading underneath it
says under the Tories 4 500 adults
convicted of sexually assaulting
children under 16 served no prison time
labor will lock up Dangerous Child
abusers so it's basically a headline and
then underneath Rishi sunak doesn't
agree with this and it's it's a shock
tactic it's gosh the Prime Minister
doesn't agree with locking up adults
convicted of sexually assaulting
children that's a awful and it's to get
you to read the next bit which is to try
to draw attention to what the labor
party would say is the conservative's
terrible record when it comes to crime
and particularly enforcement they want
to say the justice system is falling
apart and this is the way that they've
done it and it has caused a huge amount
of controversy and what are the main
criticisms people are making you know
sunak has only been an MP since what is
it 2015 so it it sort of hit his record
he's not responsible for the record that
labor are attacking I suppose so there's
two aspects of it that people have
um had a problem with first of all it's
just the the text do you think adults
convicted of sexually assaulting
children should go to prison Rishi sunat
doesn't now that is categorically untrue
yeah because it's quite obvious uh to
everyone that the Prime Minister does
agree with that when you read on what
you realize is oh that's just a kind of
it's a rhetorical device it's an
advertising trick
um it may not be the most sophisticated
but you you quite quickly realize as you
read the rest of the text okay that's
not actually what's going on they're
just trying to draw attention to the
fact that not all of not all of these
people have been convicted of these
crimes has gone to prison and that's
because of lots of issues with the
justice system so there's that aspect of
it the other criticism that's been
leveled at it which I think is
potentially more tenuous is that they
are trying to link the idea of sexual
assault of children and that crime with
the fact that Rishi sunak is a a man of
a British Indian Heritage now I think
that's a really interesting criticism
what that some in the labor party saying
is this is kind of dog whistle politics
that we were talking a week ago about
race and child exploitation child sexual
exploitation and then suddenly a week
later they have this you know quite
provocative advert you know linking
Rishi sunak as a British Indian man with
this same crime and there are lots of
people that don't like it why do you
think Liz that they're targeting sunac
personally because there's a whole host
of issues I suppose they could get into
the cost of living crisis energy bills
but they're personally attacking Rishi
sunak here
they said it's quite straightforward
which is that the conservative party is
polling worse than Michigan's personal
polling is doing slightly better and I
think that's because he's had certainly
the first few months of his Premiership
he he has achieved quite a lot when you
compare you know what some of his
predecessors have done and he he is
giving off the sort of an air of of
competence and increasing confidence and
I think they're worried that Rishi sunak
could be a lot more popular certainly
than Liz truss and Boris Johnson the
other concerns the labor party is that
their own leader kierstama polls worse
than his own party will he speak to
people activists who are knocking on
doors tell me that Kia's Dharma is not
as reviled in certain areas as Jeremy
corbyn was but people are still very
unsure about Kia starmer and they
certainly don't find him you know to be
a kind of inspirational political leader
so I think the is those two things
coming together really and it's fair to
say timing is everything in politics
isn't it but why do you think they're
doing this now well this particular ad
campaign I think is targeted at the
local elections because crime I think is
one of those things that comes up on the
doorstep people associate it with kind
of local government and labor think that
it's fertile territory for them to
attack the Tories on something that
they're prioritizing and that is what
you're seeing come through in these
social media attackers the interesting
thing is they have pivoted in their
style in their campaigning style and I
think this is what has caused the
controversy this is what has surprised
people this is really pretty aggressive
from the labor party and I would say
walking the line over whether it is
taking the moral High ground and many
even within the party think that KIA
storma's tactic seems to be we're going
to stoop as low as the Tories when it
comes to political campaigning and maybe
that will get us into government and
some people are happy that kiosnama
seems to want to roll up his sleeves and
fight dirty and others very unhappy
because they believe that that is what
distinguishes the labor party from the
conservative party that they do always
take the moral High ground and they
don't tread the line when it comes to
bending the truth in political
campaigning so interesting isn't it Liz
because there are other people that will
say hang on a second hypocrisy here
because the Tories drew that criticism
didn't they after accusing secure storm
of failing to prosecute Jimmy Savile
during partygate
former director of public prosecutions
Mrs vegan he spent most of his time
Prosecuting journalists and failing to
prosecute Jimmy Savile as far as I can
make up
the interesting thing is it's not really
the conservative party the you know the
lots of conservative MPS have said it's
disgusting but it is what we've seen
many times before with the labor party
really this is there's been a big
internal backlash it's labor MPS that
are angry with this the conservatives uh
I think are much more comfortable with
slinging mud if you like and the labor
party certain factions of it less so
they're certainly not as well versed in
doing it it isn't part usually of the
labor Playbook and so I think what this
is it's showing uh another site we've
already seen a bit of this side to kirst
armor when he you know basically got rid
of Jeremy corbyn quite unceremoniously
from his party it's a kind of he wants
to win at all costs and I think that's
uncomfortable uh within his own party
so Liz look labor aren't known for these
big attack campaigns or they don't do
them often let's just say but the
conservative party over the history for
various ad campaigns in particular the
labor isn't working one from 1979. that
was a game changer it really was and I
think the difference a lot of the time
with the labor party and the
conservatives I mean first of all it is
prioritizing these types of campaigns so
Lord Sachi has done a number of
campaigns for the conservative party and
that one in particular was one of the
one of the most effective I also
remember I think there was one in I
can't remember I think it was in the 90s
new labor new dangers yeah so that was
1997. so that was totally the devil eyes
yes
really work as well I suppose because
we've got his power I think it was
poorly timed but I think any any AD
campaign that you remember that you can
get the image of it into your mind is an
incredibly successful campaign I think
the conservatives they prioritize that
they are happy to they've got more money
and they are happy to spend that money
on those campaigns because they know how
effective they can be if you can really
grab something that is in the public
Consciousness that hasn't really been
expressed and take that and make it into
an iconic image that can change at the
course of an election
in politics you have to get the point
that's not because the people are not
intelligent enough to understand an
argument
the reverse which is that they
understand everything
but they just don't have the time for
waffle and vagueness
[Music]
he's been described as the Godfather of
negative campaigning not least because
such in Suchi were the brains behind the
labor isn't working advert that Liz
described earlier it ran during the 1979
conservative election campaign and it
was credited for bringing Margaret
Thatcher to power
why is this advert so successful and why
do you think negative campaigning works
the answer to both those points is that
politics is an adversarial activity
hit or be hit
it is not a world for the squeamish or
the faint art
and it's true as you pointed out that
Professor David Butler
certainly the most respected Authority
on British general elections
he did say to me that I was I'm quoting
him personally responsible unquote for
ruining British politics with what I
don't feel ashamed of that because
I don't think negative is all bad
the situation here in politics is that
you are in the boxing ring
your opponent has punched you in the
face
and you are bleeding
and so what are you supposed to do now
there is only one thing to do now
which is to land a blow
on your opponent's chin that knocks him
out
well we did that did win four elections
in a row and it is a it's an absolutely
crucial part of our political campaigns
work does this labor ad does it strike
the The Knockout blow then I don't know
about the answer to that they're doing
what they think they have to do I can
certainly explain this but if you want
to have if you want this blow on the
chin to work which is obviously what
they're they're trying to do you'll have
to get to the point that's what I was
saying yeah
it has to be very simple the most
powerful rallying cries
in history are simple and to the point
try these your country needs you yes
no taxation with representation one man
one vote
there wasn't anything very complicated
was there about Liberty reality
fraternity I don't mind
any of that in fact the reverse I think
it's it's a skill
an extreme skill and very hard to do and
very few people can do it and certainly
if you want my opinion about these labor
ads they don't achieve that so putting
aside the morality of his wife or
whatever it is that's all beside the
point they don't need my standard
has to do is to land the blow on the
chin that knocks them out and what do
they have to do to do that do you think
they'll have to figure that out
will they be knocking you on your door
perhaps
no that's not a chance and if they did
answer the door that's a long long time
ago but the but the lessons of all that
are as relevant now as they ever were
it's interesting isn't it because some
people are saying actually don't we need
an area where there's positive
campaigning and that will bring about a
better political debate for the country
yes you can be criticized for your
failure to bring forward a positive
vision
and you will be all you're doing is just
doing negative advertising to criticize
your opponent don't you have any
positive vision for the country yourself
I mean of course people have said that
over the entire period that I'm
describing and the answer of course
which was said at the time was that in a
general election campaign it is the job
of the leader of the party
whether the prime minister or the leader
of the opposition it is the job of that
person to point out the defects in the
opponent's position that's certainly the
job of what happens in
um published material
and one expects and assumes that the
such a person the prime minister or the
leader will have tremendously exciting
things to say about a vision for the
country and the future of the country
well of course that's very important
that's not the job of
um these political campaigns
that's a job for the leader to do and
the leader will have to find other ways
to express their fabulously exciting
vision
beyond all the headlines and Twitter
rails I suppose the big question really
is whether these types of ads have any
cut through so Liz are these ads
actually working to turn voters towards
labor well what we can say for sure is
the controversial aspect of this ad
campaign has meant that many many more
people would have seen it than they had
done otherwise so this has now been
viewed extremely widely for a social
media labor campaign it's probably one
of their most successful undercurst
armor social media attack ads no
question about that what I when I speak
to people in the labor party who are
seem to have been involved in this and
are are very much defensive of what
they've done here what they say is this
is a huge success because lots of people
are now talking about Rishi sunax record
and his government's record on crime and
I have a question mark over that because
uh I think somebody put it quite well
I'm not sure who it was at 1 critical
commentator said the only thing that I
can really remember about this ad is the
nasty taste it left in my mouth Yes and
so I don't know what effect it has
there's one more issue I think for the
labor party which is this may be a huge
success lots of people have seen it you
know it might be that it draws attention
to the toys record on crime in a way
that is positive for them Kirsten has a
real problem with his brand one of the
only things that has really cut through
on him as a leader is that when Boris
Johnson and partygate was happening Kia
starmer when he was investigated over
partygate said that he would stand down
if he was found to have broken the law
and that was one aspect of this it was a
that was building his brand around this
idea that he is a man of integrity now
if you start to go down a different road
which is he's he's now a political
leader who will win at any price who
will say anything to get into government
then suddenly you've kind of trashed
that idea of kissed armor as a man of
integrity and suddenly he's a sort of
Boris Johnson figure that will say
anything to get into into government
voters already feel that they don't know
kyostarma and I wonder if this muddies
the idea of who Kia stamma is even more
oh so so interesting to see perhaps the
next move from labor and you know we're
likely to see more campaigning as we get
closer to a general election but it's
hard to say isn't it hard question but
is the election likely to be quite as
vicious as this as we head closer to it
I think if you know these ads tell us
anything it is that it will be vicious
and I think that's because you know for
maybe the first time in quite a long
time it does feel like it's on a knife
edge it feels like that you know the
labor party are getting close to
governments and that has made them want
to push and push even more and what we
know about the conservative parties they
will fight dirty and if they think that
they are about to lose a general
election I think all bets are off so I
think it could be really aggressive
combative confrontational a couple of
years as we come to a general election
Liz don't book any leave I'm sure we're
going to be needing to talk to you in
the days the weeks I'm not going to
leave the office thanks so much Liz
thank you
my thanks to Liz Bates and Lord Sachi
and to you for listening to the Sky News
Daily with me Leah belletto
this episode was produced by Rosie
Gillett and Alex Eden our editor was
Paul stanworth